hier des 18 heures on s'est rendu aux
soirées électorales d'Emmanuel Macron au
Champ-de-Mars et de Marine Le Pen au
bois de Boulogne on avait le choix entre
les dealers du Champ de Mars ou les
prostituées du bois de Boulogne et moi
j'ai choisi les pro
stituées chez Emmanuel Macron les
soutiens étaient venus de bonheur pour
être au premier loge bien placé
parce que là les deux côtés la confiance
était au rendez-vous je suis quand même
confiant je suis confiant comment ça va
gagner c'est Marine
qui va passer
génial elle est marine allez les gens si
ce sera parfois qu'ils étaient même
prêts en découdre
tu dis quoi on sait que celui qui va
gagner je parie ma tête va gagner j'ai
marre Le Pen le dress code était assez
chic et élégant
[Musique]
alors que chez Macron bah ils avaient
carte blanche les mecs
[Musique]
comme ça tous les jours de tes
personnalités ORL on a pu compter sur
Stevie Boulay
mais c'est en marche qui a créé la
surprise avec des stars de renom comme
Jules
et logique qui est d'ailleurs passé avec
son poteau sch oui
de 20h les militants des deux parties
avaient un petit message plus ou moins
mignon pour leur adversaire qu'elle
revienne
bravo mais c'est pas cette année
Macron dégage
l'ambiance est bonne on a aussi voulu
prendre la température dans la rue avant
les résultats regardez on vive cette
élection c'est également rendu dans la
rue et notamment dans le 19e
arrondissement de Paris à Belleville
alors si certains semblaient plutôt ok
pour l'élection de Marine Le Pen avec
Marie Vive Le Pen ok d'autres étaient
carrément Thanos rien qu'en entendant
son nom oh il est là tout oui
et n'avait qu'une seule obsession à son
sujet et Marine
pourquoi il me passe on connaît pas son
mari je n'ai jamais connu son mari moi
il faut qu'on sache que qui c'est son
mari avant de quitter le 19e
arrondissement on s'est rendu dans un
petit bar où notre code de popularité
n'était pas trop au top
ensuite on a pris la direction du 16e et
de la Porte d'Auteuil on a dû montrer
patte blanche et sortir nos passeports
devant les passants
sur place on a rencontré des gens qui
avaient un avis bien tranché sur toute
cette campagne électorale
c'est chiant mais c'est à chier c'est
nul c'était mou c'était chiant enfin
c'était mou quoi pour vivre cette soirée
électorale les habitants du 16e
arrondissement avaient prévu les choses
en grand
on va se faire de bons sandwich au thon
et du côté des pronostics certains ont
tenté d'imaginer les résultats
définitifs même si on n'est pas sûr sûr
de leur calcul je dirais 54 % pour
Macron et je dirais bien
51% pour Marine Le Pen mais bon peu
importe car on pense que dans le fond
ils auraient préféré un autre président
Cyril Hanouna c'est de la balle pourquoi
pas cirer
incroyable et ça c'est exceptionnel
j'adore les gens sont fabuleux
savent qu'ils vont devoir broder de
longues minutes avant l'annonce des
résultats il y en a un alors j'ai rien
contre lui mais c'est plus possible
c'est le boulot Gilles le boulot
franchement il est très sympa il est
franchement on dirait qu'il travaille
chez catavana il est très sympa mais dès
18h30 j'ai le boulot c'est quand même
monsieur banalité quoi c'est le gars
sans déconner c'est un truc de ouf quoi
tu t'es devant une piscine il fait
attention tu vas prendre de l'eau ah non
mais le gars tu te dois tu étais au
soleil attention quand même non mais
c'est une tasse totale il est très sympa
mais faut aller limite franchement c'est
pas possible
mais regardez-le deux scénarios sont
possibles de ces scénario sont
envisageables ce soir la victoire de
Marine Le Pen ou celle d'Emmanuel Macron
logique que dire de ce score de Marine
Le Pen c'est une défaite partout
maintenant dans un taxi un taxi parisien
avec Guillaume Debré qui est monté à
bord remonte plutôt à l'arrière
Daniel Cohn-Bendit bonsoir bonsoir
comment faut-il vous présenter Dani con
Bendit formidable
c'est dommage parce que à force de
vouloir être neutre il est devenu lisse
puis totalement transparent et donc en
fait c'est voilà c'est un tissu de
banalité il y a pas de personnalité
c'est presque une potiche je vais dire
respectueusement mais je trouve ça sympa
il faut être honnête il a perdu son âme
et ses qualités de journaliste
TF1 a envoyé ses journalistes un peu
partout en France pour l'événement et un
deux et que Arras pour voir comment les
personnes âgées allaient voter et qui
dit personne âgée dit bien sûr syndrome
d'Isabelle Morini boss de Daniel Moreau
c'est-à-dire que la personne parle c'est
long et en fait à un moment décroche
sans balai bon pour vous Daniel
évidemment c'est la possibilité de voter
la figurez-vous qu'après 65 ans de vie
citoyenne j'ai failli manquer mon
premier rendez-vous électoral
et elle du premier tour blocage de dos
pas possible de faire un kilomètre en
bus
vous pouvez voter là et ben voilà avec
ces derniers taxis de la Marne pour
transporter les gens oui merci Daniel on
ne demande pas d'humour à Arras
et vous savez et sur TF1 c'est pas comme
chez nous tu vois Daniel Daniel Provence
je te kiffe mais là
allez il y a deux possibilités ce soir
c'est où Emmanuel Macron ou Marine Le
Pen on se rappelle c'est un truc de ouf
sans déconner c'est un truc de ouf allez
il y en a un qui a pas passé une bonne
soirée c'est ton guide David mechkid le
soutien l'ancien soutien d'Éric Zemmour
Marine Le Pen a perdu mais en plus il
s'est fait recal de la rasoir là il
s'est fait recal de ouf
à 19h30 il a essayé de participer à la
soirée au Pavillon d'Armenonville il a
pas été pris bah je peux vous dire c'est
retrouver dans le calque
c'est pas la même soirée regarde
spécial de TF1 était sur place pour
choper au micro les personnalités qui
soutiennent Emmanuel Macron et 1h11 plus
tard ils ont eu quelqu'un regardez
VIP parce qu'on attend ce soir
évidemment beaucoup de personnalités il
y aura sans doute aussi des
personnalités du monde du spectacle du
monde du sport nous tendons donc notre
micro pour vous à toutes ces
personnalités qui passeront ici sur le
Champ de Mars quelle personnalité va
être
ou encore Christian Clavier
Jean-Marc Dumontais bonsoir vous êtes
producteur producteur de spectacle on
vous connaît sur TF1 pour être le
producteur de Nicolas canteloupe en
plusieurs fois
il y a peut-être Jean-Marc dumonté bien
mais bon sinon ta personne d'autre sinon
j'ai le sosie de Mel Gibson
à 20h pile c'est donc le grand moment
c'était le résultat sur toutes les
chaînes on a pu voir s'afficher le
visage d'Emmanuel Macron moi j'étais sûr
qu'à un moment il allait avoir un
matelotté je sais plus ouh là tout est
benaïve il devrait mettre une totale
et donc Emmanuel Macron est apparu et
chaque scène a fait sa petite mise en
scène regardez après lui président
Marine Le Pen sera-t-elle la première
femme à montrer à l'Élysée Emmanuel
Macron sera-t-il le premier président
être élu depuis l'instauration du
calcaire de ce jour
date cette victoire et celle des forces
comme François Mitterrand et Jacques
Chirac Emmanuel Macron sera-t-il réélu
pour un second mandat Marine Le Pen
sera-t-elle la première femme Elysée et
Marianne va vous annoncer le résultat
il est 20h et vous le voyez Emmanuel
Macron est réélu avec 58% des voix
et cette Emmanuel Macron qui est réélu
[Musique]
Ia
la plus originale de donner les
résultats bravo M6 exceptionnel vivement
que TF1 et M6 rallye pour que Nicolas
terradeur reprenne tout ça en main on a
trouvé ça tellement bien d'ailleurs
qu'on s'est dit qu'on allait faire la
même chose dorénavant pour annoncer les
grands disparus de TPMP regarde
Eric hamoulet 2015-2016 l'âme disparue
en chouette en 2016 Rachid Arab 2017
Christophe carrière transféré dans
l'émission de Benaim en 2017 Adrien
Lemaître de chroniques en 2018 Doc
Gynéco aucune nouvelle depuis septembre
2019 Noam cartozo coupé au pilote de la
rentrée 2020 Paolo Lady annoncé comme la
grosse recrue de 2021 et à 96% des votes
les Français pensent qu'on ne reverra
plus dans TPMP en 2022 nous le
découvrons ensemble Nicolas pernicoff
[Applaudissements]
on peut plus charrier ici c'est clair
maintenant bon nous on était donc au
rassemblement organisé par les deux
candidats vous allez voir que l'ambiance
n'était pas tout à fait la même après
20h regardez regardez les résultats
regardez c'est magnifique qu'on vient le
moment tant attendu de l'annonce des
résultats les supporters d'Emmanuel
Macron étaient en plein kif face à la
Tour Eiffel c'est le résultat
[Applaudissements]
président de la République en revanche
chez Marine Le Pen petit déception
forcément
[Applaudissements]
été prévu pour faire une grosse teuf
dans la foulée à partir de ce moment-là
c'était vraiment deux salles de ambiance
dans les soirées électorales
[Musique]
obtenu par accordiste
de l'extrême droite chère marine
[Musique]
alors il annonce des résultats n'a pas
été vécue de la même manière bien
entendu un par les promos et les
prolapen dans les différents
rassemblements du arène on a vu des
déçus et certains étaient très très
déçus on vous a fait une compil des
réactions bien entendu on verra celle de
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
mais non c'est pas possible
bande de cons
tiens regarde-la
alors entre l'annonce des résultats le
discours d'Emmanuel Macron c'est la fête
sur le Champ de Mars et on a pu voir des
spectateurs ou des militants en marche
se déhancher grâce au DJ voilà que qui
était qui avait été très bien
il y avait aussi des ministres et
c'était pas les derniers sur le
dancefloor je peux vous dire
[Musique]
je fais la même chose Daniel tu fais la
même chose avec moi
du tout à 20h14 Marine Le Pen a pris la
parole on reconnaissant sa défaite mais
la candidatte du rassemblement national
est-elle malgré tout confiante pour la
suite regarde les Français manifestent
ce soir le sud à contre-pouvoir à celui
d'Emmanuel Macron en effet je crains ce
soir que le quinquennat qui s'ouvre ne
rompre pas avec les pratiques
méprisantes et brutales du précédent et
qu'Emmanuel Macron ne fera rien pour
réparer les fractures qui divisent notre
pays et font souffrir nos compatriotes
pour éviter cette accaparement des
pouvoirs par quelques-uns plus que
jamais je poursuivrai mon engagement
pour la France et les Français
l'énergie la persévérance et l'affection
que vous me connaissez
[Applaudissements]
pas drôle alors voilà c'est vrai voilà
quoi pour changer le casting un peu on
dirait plus belle la vie là c'est bon
des autres gens là alors qu'une histoire
d'élection du débats sur les plateaux
télé et qui dit débats sur les plateaux
télés Rachida
de Paris toute la soirée pour distribuer
des punchlines alors hier soir des 20h25
c'était le grand retour du show Dati
regarde est-ce que vous allez plutôt
rejoindre Emmanuel Macron on sait que
certains de chez vous ce soir à ne pas
c'est votre question ce soir
je vous ai pas demandé de décoder mes
propos là je lui pose la question je
peux lui dire direct
personne mais vous avez pas le monopole
de quoi que ce soit et on voit comment
vous avez fracturer les territoires vous
êtes responsable d'une grande partie du
séparation en France faut que vous
l'entendiez ça non mais attendez vous
avez fracturé le pays depuis des années
je n'ai rien je n'ai jamais gouverné
madame latine on vous parlez
la transition
alors quand un président est élu il y a
une autre grande tradition c'est la
traversée de Paris le mec traverse la
ville pour rejoindre le lieu de la fête
escortée par des dizaines de policiers
journalistes ça c'est la tradition voilà
moi je fais comme ça aussi pour la des
rendez-vous pour le kif comme ça tu vois
je vais manger une glace avec des potes
quand même voilà et pour l'occasion les
chaînes de télé mettent toutes leurs
équipes sur le coup mais hier soir sur
France 2 c'est toujours Jeff bytembert
franchement lui le pauvre c'est une
tasse pour je l'adore en plus il est bon
mais à chaque fois il est où Jeff euh
bah tu me l'envoies là ok tu me
l'envoies regardez miskine il était en
charge de dessus le Président il a
galéré
jeff vitambert est sur sa moto et on
risque de le perdre Emmanuel Macron oui
qui se dirige vers le Champ de Mars mais
qui prend un chemin assez particulier là
puisque là la voiture que nous avons
suivie et nous avons peut-être été neuré
ça a été le cas il y a 5 ans n'était pas
celle du président mais celle du Premier
ministre visiblement le président se
rendent à Matignon et ça je n'y crois
pas beaucoup Jeff vitambert encore lui
nous signale que Emmanuel Macron a
quitté l'Élysée alors
si ce n'est pas le cas nous allons
retourner à l'Élysée l'attendre en tout
cas il y a beaucoup d'effervescence
autour du Champ de Mars c'est le gars
récurrent de cette soirée est-ce la
voiture du président ou pas on va faire
une petite pause on retrouve j'évite
un verre et cette fois je vous le
certifie à 100% c'est le concours celui
du président Macron réélu qui se dirige
vers le Champ de Mars
il est magnifique j'habite à nazi
vous êtes bien le président Macron c'est
vous monsieur non je reconnais pas le
gars non mais c'est sûr on a nous on a
donc pu voir aussi des militants
d'Emmanuel Macron faire la fête de
Marine Le Pen un peu moins dans la darka
on était au Rassemblement pour la suite
de la soirée regarde
après les résultats de 20h on était les
recueillir les réactions à chaudes et
sympathisants on est trop contents c'est
le bonheur là un peu déçu on voulait on
voulait plus on voulait mieux on voulait
gagner
c'est super
évidemment
sont arrivés pour leur discours avec
d'un côté Emmanuel Macron tout ça
j'entourai de sa femme et d'enfants
qu'on connaît pas et de l'autre Marine
Le Pen entouré de beaucoup trop de monde
s'il vous plaît
il est possible et si ce qui était au
Champ de Mars n'ont pas pu profiter d'un
petit coup gratos bah ouais je pensais
qu'elle est un petit bar au moins mais
il y a pas de petit barbe en revanche du
côté du bois de Boulogne ils avaient
tout prévu avec même une cuvée spéciale
Marine Le Pen qu'ils ont bien dégusté
apparemment on a tous bu pas un verre
ensemble avec la convivialité alors
forcément on est déçu ce soir mais en
même temps il y a les législatives enfin
chacun des deux candidats a fait son
petit discours et on pense que le
président Emmanuel Macron a su séduire
son public
[Musique]
alors j'ai des textos de ma mère tu es
très beau tu as une barre mille va après
ou quoi
Baba tu es plus beau que le président et
tu es plus intelligent merci maman
c'est normal c'est ma mère c'est pas que
je suis con comme une babouche
à 21h33 c'était l'arrivée d'Emmanuel
Macron au Champ de Mars et son arrivée
fait énormément parler en musique
c'était la même 5 ans avant l'Aude à la
joie c'était l'hymne de l'Union
européenne c'est j'aime bien ça écoute
souvent dans la voiture
cette fois il n'est pas arrivé tout seul
puisqu'il était avec tous les enfants
cachés de Benjamin Castaldi
[Applaudissements]
Macron qui est en train d'arriver au
côté de sa femme Brigitte au Champ de
Mars donc sur anime bien connu pour le
président de la République l'Aude à la
joie celle-là même qu'il avait
accompagné au Louvre en 2017 au pied de
la pyramide cette fois c'est au pied de
la Tour Eiffel qui est manuel Macron est
en train de cheminer et il est entouré
la dernière fois il était seul
évidemment il y a là un message vous le
voyez il est non seulement entouré de sa
femme mais aussi de beaucoup de monde de
beaucoup de jeunes
alors évidemment le message que Emmanuel
Macron voulait faire passer c'est que je
me tourne vers l'avenir bien entendu
mais nous ça nous a plutôt rappelé un
clip regardez
[Musique]
des messages pour les jours à venir
on écrit sur les murs à l'encre de nos
belles on dessine tout ce que l'on
voudrait
sur Twitter on avait un autre
détournement très darka vous allez voir
apparemment Emmanuel Macron n'était pas
accompagné de Brigitte hier mais d'une
star internationale
[Musique]
Jackson
moi j'ai kiffé je kiffé la tenue de
Brigitte
hyper stylée hyper stylé franchement
à 21h40 Emmanuel Macron a donc prononcé
le discours de sa rédaction il a voulu
remercier les Français sans oublier que
certains sont en colère il a donné sa
feuille de route pour les 5 prochaines
années et il était très attendu ce
discours je crois que certains
n'attendais même plus que d'autres
puisqu'il y a des mecs au Champs de Mars
qui étaient très très chaud regardez
[Applaudissements]
vous pensez qu'il a entendu ça bien sûr
c'est incroyable
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]